what I am greatest night ever check
check one two
security video B me and Mike Boyd in the
backseat
[Music]
yeah real good a lot of clients a lot of
stuff is [ __ ] we're so busy well I get
just like a hyper you know like in that
video game where you going real fast but
then you have like the boost button [ __ ]
where we're powering it we're going on I
promised you and look at it I really
liked it man yeah that was fresh you saw
we put some joints on our our playlist
this week no first of all you might not
know you know it's funny we haven't
really hit it that hard to feel I'm
starting something pretty cool for doing
that bro that's why you know it's funny
I asked to go fuel in the office with
our favorite songs playlist this notion
of thank you this notion of like my
concern that you have a little bit too
much perfection in you yeah what do you
think like on a like on some friendship
like I really think it's a big deal man
I really wish I could convince you but
like look you're an artist so like I'm
not trying to convince but I think it's
a healthy conversation like I think I'll
probably drill it into you every time we
know each other the rest of our lives
I don't think artists real like I'm so
good at one thing which is like the
reality of attention and how [ __ ]
happens and that's all I got
it's disproportionately like the [ __ ]
that I believe on this issue [ __ ] man
since we connected it's you more
open-minded to it than you were before
yes and it's a process do you consume
music yeah and like you're like like who
do you who you listen to right now you
need to code you need to literally DM
them I'm like yo we should work together
no no I mean every time anybody puts out
a joint that you like yeah because my
theory is that if some like [ __ ]
country star or some up-and-coming
rapper that boy puts you on or some
whatever alternative or some [ __ ]
Bangladeshi kid that you think did some
fly [ __ ] the reason I say that is my
hope is that like one every tens like yo
what's up let's do it I'm coming through
let's go in studio people need to put
out music man so Boyd what's going on
[Music]
Monday through Sunday
like Jeezy is that just Freddy no he's
doing when you get regular studio this
is like a way of life you know
right now future every years like I
think I'm doing a lot more like it's
like [ __ ] yeah you're an interesting guy
because you're like you're also a little
bit live like you just beat me to it
you're a little bit of like a holistic
artist yeah like I think I'm gonna do
futon I think I almost set that up
because they're doing it in queer voices
and like I get to cure it like I think
they've always have to be you know I
also think I also think your food joint
is real I'm sorry your your merchandise
is real I think you got a good eye for
that yeah man I think about the same one
I put out a [ __ ] I put out a mixtape
this week the airplane project
[Music]
man you know real tar your real talented
artist man you need to put out music but
you need to figure out the key is the
normal format isn't gonna work for you
this minute because the way you think
about it like I'll give you I'll give
you a good example in business there's
[ __ ] that I spend months on thinking
about putting together I pop it out and
it doesn't click in 24 hours and I know
it's not gonna be what I want it to be
and I'm literally on that [ __ ] and
that's a whole different like mindset
where you just like completely deploy
the obnoxious humility of the market is
the market is the market yeah game over
all I know is that like I'm very
interested in the collaborations of
people that you admire or you're into
because I think there's something there
what you need to do is create a system
well this you need to create a system
where you get the leverage with the end
consumer
so those [ __ ] guys come to you
instead of you weren't worrying about or
debating or being curious of what would
happen if let me tell you something else
that I'm gonna really [ __ ] unleash you
right now cuz it's gonna really matter
right let me tell you the biggest
mistake you're making in your mind from
afar on [ __ ] you put it on wax you put
real [ __ ] that you know means something
to your culture on wax what you don't
realise yet is you could say the same
[ __ ] 79 times over the next nine years
in different contexts and ways I'd still
pull it off there's nothing in the
airplane project I haven't said before
that's why I rock didn't understand it
cuz he's like I know this it's just less
polished version of great [ __ ] you've
said before that's why I understood his
reaction the difference was the way I
packaged the thoughts I knew would
penetrate
the fact that you can basically make
Cleopatra all over again and call it
brown princess and 18 months on some
whatever the emerging EDM [ __ ] joint
is that my man is liberating I guess do
you understand yeah because I think that
[ __ ] with me a lot which is like but I
already talked about patience in a video
two years ago until I realized yeah but
if nobody heard it nobody heard it
sometimes it's the fourth project of
they still the same exact [ __ ] there's
so much you could do man you can do so
much yeah you can do so much powerful
[ __ ] look what happened yesterday
you can social commentate on that from a
different perspective that might just be
the moment you could or you may decide
to let it pass that's all cool tomorrow
you may fall in love like there's just
so much I don't know that's worth
honestly when I hear that that's where
the [ __ ] stops and ends for me yeah of
course if you have ideas you need to
figure out a process to get them to
[ __ ] see the world otherwise I
literally think the hundred greatest
songs of all time never happened they
just passed through John Lennon's head
like right Michael Jackson just didn't
put it on wax dude the biz depth is what
the distribution is more or equally
important to the actual song look people
think people think we're gonna make a
hot joint and somehow miraculously rap
camera is gonna pick it up everybody's
gonna see it and away it goes what is
your back go to step back now that we
got a few minutes how do you think about
songs when I hear seven or eight you're
like having white what's your process
so I can start the to track I'm just
getting in the studio making a song like
Atlanta does I'm good and I don't like
doing [ __ ] that doesn't interest you see
him - because I'm good at it like I
could do a mocking like a blues song
tomorrow and I can make a pong a song
another day
which is the Dominion hidden the next
day but it doesn't necessarily mean I
should I'm talented enough to hear all
of that [ __ ] right but I don't
necessarily like making like straight
rap music things like that my whole MO
is making issues than music like using
the artists that I'm into like yep and
for me it's time you know tides
luckily a patch or one of your favorite
songs yeah that took time in my head I
needed to produce that in my head I was
like how the [ __ ] do I make a dancehall
rhythm and put an Indian sample on it
but it'd not be the lead how do I do
that without like if you took the sample
out is it still a good song how do you
do that because in history of anybody
sampling India music India Timberland
whatever you take the sample out the
songs done is just the [ __ ] bass drum
that's what I mean and because I think
about music that deeply you know it's
just not like a simple like
oh I can make a song about it
you don't say because I understand it
takes me longer time to make my copies
listen in the cold place parachutes it's
the entire week and I was like just
because for me that's more interesting I
can I could wake up tomorrow and do it
what about what about what about what
about the second you're done hearing
that and you've decided that what about
whipping out your phone hitting the
memos app I'm just talking about what's
going through your mind and put it out
what about what about [ __ ] share in
the process right like what about that
that's unique like what I think you know
one thing that's interesting about that
I'm starting to try to understand about
myself is like I started a long-form
YouTube show in 2006 like like Google
flew me out in 2006 I was like what are
you doing like I don't like like even
you know obviously I'm thinking about it
a lot because of the airplane project
like I make different [ __ ] man daily
beast different daily beast the start of
a genre like everybody blogged before
like what first person people didn't
have a dude [ __ ] following them do
you know what's interesting to me is
about how I think about things meaning
so I hear something like that I'm like
that's so creative that's so right and
then I think about leverage thank you
right I think about leverage I think so
much of what I do is to have so much
leverage that when I cash it in
something good happens right like to me
you're a foregone conclusion success
wise
foregone conclusion you will be
successful it's a foregone conclusion
who makes a bigger impact the artist
that stays true the whole way and then
gets put on later in their career or the
artist that not deviates or sells out
but breaks out well yeah currency well
listen here's something interesting
though let me let me tell you something
though
The Beatles right like to me I'm
fascinated by do you gather the
attention and then deploy it so so it's
funny I'm just saying I'm actually going
to we replace me because I was at
charity events a couple hours ago I used
to think like 10 years ago that I would
make a lot of money one day and I'd be a
really good guy and be where there's old
guys giving out money and now I just
give out money along the way and there's
something about like the thought of like
making an impact like that I wonder if
like like you think about Gaga or Eminem
before things that nature leave you look
what Eminem is doing right now it's
making a real he has a real chance like
a real impact he's going at it right now
in like a real smart way and like I
don't know I there's something so
incredible when you have people
listening it's like oh [ __ ]
that's good loved having you on man
people fun people people are loving it
so much we're getting such good feedback
people don't want to [ __ ] face facts
people don't want to face facts man
we're getting exposed at scale people
are blaming social media it's laughable
I think this is bad though I mean so
what's better I would say to say hiding
no no I would just just say let's look
like let's strike the bounce off I'll
say I don't know but you're the only way
for me right like the biggest thing for
me just like you you have to make really
big important decisions and all that
stuff and so one of the things that I
try to do you know is have to be logged
out of my accounts until it's time to
post
you don't mean like that by the way I
think that's phenomenal yeah here's my
thing everybody needs to do everybody
everybody yeah like I just don't
understand what the difference is
between [ __ ] reading a stream on the
bus or amongst people or like the person
who's reading the newspaper or like we
consume content that is a huge
difference Roland we would watch Donna
yeah we also will be looking at great
photos you wouldn't also be listening to
the radio you would also be doing all
those things you just you just wouldn't
do with bro I'm someone I'm not - I'm
listening I felt that a TD anxiety and
you know and I've been like alright you
got him look it's a push platform logout
you got it be about your jokes right now
and you wanna be about your pictures and
don't be going down that rabbit hole is
a real bad that rabbit hole was consumed
by something else in the past this
notion that we were miraculously more
productive in 1964 is a huge farce the
end we just did different things we we
romanticize reading a book for like
watching The Cosby Show like I [ __ ]
sat on my fat ass and played [ __ ]
Mike Tyson's punch-out for an hour and a
half then watched [ __ ] the facts of
life Three's Company
like it sometime but you're doing one
thing but why I think anxiety was less
you were still wasting time bro and
getting DS and apps that's fine
but you're doing one thing
anxiety is not an all-time high
we're just having a proper conversation
around anxiety people have always had
anxiety think about this men you're in
your bag the first thing you do is you
don't look at your girl you let them let
a man say you're like [ __ ] you're
leading the witness brownie before every
time before I go to sleep I find myself
saying I think as a habitual I'm
fascinated about habitual selected
habitual accident confidence sometimes
you play your phone in 30 seconds before
I consciously am realizing what I'm
doing yeah for my habitual aspect but I
also agree that somewhere else a yellow
pad when I see yellow pads
I think smart shits happened
you're artists you're doing this
no it's your life that has to be there
me as an artist your eye thinks that the
fact that my man here put a medium at a
pedestal is sad the difference between
this and that is zero it's what's on it
no you're like a comic that works no no
no no no no you're better than this and
his language in his language yours is
more pure and his historic to me it's
all it's all the same [ __ ] but then you
read like an ass book and that [ __ ] like
was into the brick I'm saying whatever
your style is right stop all right
that's fine
I'm saying this new just bro like by the
way like I'm not gonna front like I said
I'm not in 2017 like it boys I mean
let's be real like I'm not [ __ ]
around it's Google Docs for days come on
absent [ __ ] we got new takes we got old
table it's just you know I think we
should go I think we should go to that
tree and carve some of our thoughts into
it and that's how that's you know people
put we put mediums on pedestals instead
of what's actually being put on those
mediums you you haven't been able to use
social media my life yields my leave my
life for social media zero a lot of
times I'm like [ __ ] them inside too much
using too much tech on and [ __ ] it
gets me in it I mean a little time apart
I don't like
I just don't [ __ ] do that so that's
always my go back to it
there's majority of days I find myself
saying I don't know I want to be outside
camping I want to be [ __ ] of all the
present healthcare choice
anti-technology propaganda
this was our joke or whole life growing
up and now people are like this my man
Sugar's gone is my man you you you guys
guys you can have both here's my thing
though you're in control do you
but don't [ __ ] on the other person's
thing like I'm not judging anybody else
it's like my whole thing for a lot of
people is like people keep throwing
things at me like yo this this is
something cool but I'm never like yo
like I'll never start like yo why you
putting the paper in the envelope on a
pedestal I'm just responding I'm in
counter punching on this issue like to
me life's about choices I think the
things super interesting about social or
digital what-have-you is first of all I
bet you everybody this table agrees that
10 years from now we're deeper into the
tech world not further away now do I
think there'll be some cool hipster
countercultural like yo I'm out of 500
day detox I haven't been on of course
because anything that swings it's like
social itself Facebook and Twitter we're
hoping snapchat came along and people
are like yeah like you know it just
swings but the punchline is this entire
conversation for me is the continuation
of the gross underestimation of the
human being we are so much more capable
like like anxiety hasn't happened
because technology anxiety is happening
because we are evolving in the
conversations the conversation around
alcoholism forty years ago was a
disaster like we're finally having good
conversations around mental health like
I'm thrilled we talked about it more
like there was guys you know many people
like you know what guys
bullying isn't a phenomenon of social
media bullying is a phenomenon of
parents creating fake realities for
children like there's a lot of variables
that go into this it's not just one
thing I mean when I was a kid
bullying like your parents are getting
so involved now that you feel they need
to help you out of it not you work
yourself out of it now kids have
diseases and bullying's extreme like I
got it but like but like this thought
that like that like we're not looking at
the counter angle to this so for example
the amount of kids that are happy today
at 14 because I got their friends on
Twitch that literally twenty years ago
would have been miserable and would have
been sick and would have been depressed
because everybody had school [ __ ] with
them and they'd have somewhere to go
like twitch to find their own we're just
looking at the negative we're not
looking at the pro here's what I think
on a the biggest macro and then
everything else is secondary we were
full of [ __ ] and it's time for the
[ __ ] day of reckoning and we're in
the B and by the way we're in the
beginning shits about to get way worse
shits about to hit the fan for everybody
shits good we're getting naked
this is the beginning of us getting
naked we're systematically over the next
two decades gonna face our [ __ ]
truths that we don't want to [ __ ]
face like lots and lots and lots of
things like every single issue there's
nowhere to hide the media the media
whether controlled by a dictator or by
rich tycoons was the filter of our
thoughts now everybody's getting exposed
so like first we have to like face some
real creeps like like like I don't think
like right we're gonna have to face some
real troops man like like we need some
real corrections across the board and
we're just gonna go through that cycle
like everything bad is gonna get out in
the open I think misinformation
and we're not having a misinformation
yes so misinformation was always
happening though like let's take that
back yeah here is the most different
thing that's happening if you have power
you're not safe the biggest shift today
from 30 years ago is if you have
leverage you can't use it to control the
narrative all we are is the serendipity
of like moments in time like I think
everybody's like got a really like is
gonna struggle cuz it's a chemical thing
here's what's always been historic when
you're in the middle of real change
you're always like what the [ __ ] because
you don't have the backdrop - right
right like we're in the mid so we're in
the mists of real change the internet so
we at like this have been my whole point
the whole time and you as like the great
historian of my concept which I
appreciate like I believe in the
difference honestly dude like like I
don't know if I've ever been more
humbled I'm being dead serious and like
I get flattered like I'm always like
pretty like happy and likes aprotic poof
it's [ __ ] you know like I'm xxx like
you're in it love it anyway I guess it
makes me think he's super smart that
he's so deep into my goodness that I
loved when I was like oh this is great
because when you do airport Gary is on
the streets sometimes
and then this is all the pace but he's
[ __ ] hustling almost okay and he
doesn't care because everything by the
way this goes back to my point because
the white wares dream jackets like
everybody's doing everything everything
everything but everything's set up for
Getty Images bro everything I know about
future is his [ __ ] is perfect his jewels
are / everything's perfect that's true
and what I think he's leveraging which I
makes which I think makes him unique is
that it's like no it's not like that
here's the best part area dirty I don't
even know its brain kid I'm slick I'm
like when I hear these stories I get
really excited because it speaks to a
whole lot how crazy you look I put it on
wax I'm like you're crazy but I think
you're doing a lot of good things but
yeah you look kind of insane in those
moments you it's when you don't
understand the actual unaccept like it
look it's funny I hear stuff yeah and
sometimes I'm like I'm real smart and I
really do like I run the extreme of like
being really really smart and really
knowing it and then being completely
Livius to certain [ __ ] and then I'm so
on and in those two extremes comes what
I think you've sniffed out uniquely by
the way that's what it is like I don't
even know what I'm doing you should
sometimes and other times I really know
the macro number you think this is a
fundamental good versus evil
[Music]
I feel like fear is like sugar it's
easier to tap into and you can scan the
pasture a little bit tougher to execute
in scale yeah but that's I think I agree
I won Dancing generally you know I think
I think Voldemort is slightly powerful
very 51 52 to 48 I think human nature
did I just win the sphere and then and
then give the love to kind of suppress
it well this so what do you think this
is a Grey's own right and I think that's
happening that it's either one or the
other I think I think all evil or all
love I actually think it's that
what's the series act I think if we're
gonna be 30 I think where you have
thank you two for you and don't forget I
think I posted about a couple I think I
think I think I think fear wins in the
micro and love yeah and I think when
we're in moments of fear
it feels we're so not super interesting
to me is this whole notion that I really
think everybody's famous or the notion
of like how many people are you famous
to micro Fame like it's just the whole
thing's being redefined it's like like I
think we might have said in our podcast
like the fact that I genuinely think the
30 most famous people on Instagram are
unbelievably more famous than the 30
most famous people like not on Instagram
like [ __ ] is getting so interesting I'm
fascinated by how famous you really need
to be till it goes somewhere we're like
a lot of people know who you are like a
lot a lot like him yeah Drake well
exactly like if Rihanna you can walk
yeah Rihanna like you guys not ask you a
question yeah so I think yeah why is um
because I really think that this is a
very disproportionate time where the
young people of our society are
impacting from the ground up instead of
top-down but can I say something the
reason why I like to hang out with
people who are older than me is I think
that I don't have is wisdom wisdom is
like yeah I just have to have a lot of
lists I have a lot of natural wisdom no
no no but I think serious a little bit
like like so what's interesting you
might find this interesting
this is super interesting back to like
being hardcore about my content I don't
say that often yeah I spent an
unbelievable amount of time as a kid
with very old people here's what I know
is that we are really really bad as a
great as a as a being of like thinking
things through in a 360 way when we
either like the way it turned out
or we don't so what uh you know it's
funny this has been the theme of our
conversation a little bit tonight my
favorite thing my favorite thing about
how I go through all of this is I feel
when I lose or things don't go my way
that I truly deserve it in such a deep
way when you just talk about me losing
it all
the only thing when I talk about that
[ __ ] here's my punchline on that if it
happens it should have happened I
deserved it to happen and like to me
that I spend a lot of time thinking
about that I like when bad things happen
because I think if I'm gonna enjoy the
fruits of the victories I have to learn
from the things that I [ __ ] up on you
have to respect the game more than you
respect yourself like like in a weird
way if the respect the game more than
what you want out of the game like you
have but no but I'm super said no
because that takes a lot of honest I'm
telling you right now it's so
interesting and I never thought about
this about the young thing I'm like oh
[ __ ] like while we were talking the
other part of my brain is like oh [ __ ]
that's gonna be the punchline I spent my
first twenty years with [ __ ] 80 year
olds I when I'm 80 I'm gonna spend all
my time in 20 years it's gonna get worse
what I'm doing right now is gonna get
worse it's gonna wait to see me at 63 be
like hey fourteen-year-old girl come
over here like like that's my you know
the airport Gary's crazy who's that
you'll be like on his knees in front of
a queue like it happened even before I
was filming thank God I it was when
snapchat was popping snapchat was
popping and I couldn't tell couldn't see
I didn't know what it was but I'd saw
literally exactly in the corner of my
eye a couple times they're like there's
some yellow habit that these kids are
like that's how I first knew about
snapchat and I went to the App Store and
look for a yellow app nothing
and I'm like some shit's going down
there you know what I mean like you know
there's like there's a party like why I
might like get in dorm and like there's
a party I'm not anything like I was like
there's something wrong
so finally like I caught it like I saw
somebody again and I like went in her
[ __ ] she's like 14 I'm like all in it
and I look in the dad's like [ __ ] are
you doing I was like yo the first thing
that has always worked for me is never
allowing somebody to have leverage on
you that's good that would like me to
like that's great but I don't even but
like the key is to like I've gotten to
the point where I don't even realize I'm
missing it anymore because you can cut
it becomes practice honestly I'll give
you a good example look at our table
right now do you know how serious amount
of food this is for so many people
around the world right so I look at this
right this is how I look at your
question there's so much to eat you
don't need
so I don't think like oh I'm gonna go
like like for you right it's like oh
[ __ ] I hate that person but that person
is the person that plays the record or
that person picks the playlist for the
84 million person playlist on Spotify or
SoundCloud I'm I'm kind of just like man
like like I don't even like like I'm
like to me this is why if you really
break down what I'm always saying I'm
just like brings so much value to the
end person so that you have the most
leverage Amazon gives us the best thing
we love Amazon because it's the best
buying experience thus Amazon will kill
everybody else cuz they're the best of
the consumer I want your control of the
thing that most people see because if
you bring the most value then you have
the leverage everybody comes to me
because I'm giving value at scale with
no expectation of anything else can I
tell you something can I tell you
something hi can I tell you something
I'm gonna give you a real like something
really just hit me I think you should
shut everything out you should shut
everything I think maybe you could you
could take actually the passwords on
your social you know maybe follow my
usual I think you should keep your
passwords on and just go reply to every
single person you need to go insular for
a year you your [ __ ] and your fans and
nothing else that truth always wins
I don't it's unbelievable how like I've
never had scrutiny at this level from
people I respect or bigger people than
right this minute
going on and I've never felt more calm
about it it's interesting like how
momentum I apologize because I know what
the [ __ ] I'm up to because I know what
I'm up to like how I am has a lot to do
with the way I was parented where how I
grew up a million different variables
but like in its current state of the
Union like this second I just know how
it's gonna play out but I also think
you'd be this time
but that's the center in the center part
like I just realized like even with good
[ __ ] certainly good good things
happening to me now I thought like that
[ __ ] was gonna face like some of the
problems or make me feel better but you
know everybody tells you that [ __ ] but
you don't [ __ ] take it you know what
that's you know it's crazy you're lucky
you didn't get pop out cuz that show
would have exposed and accelerated the
negative exposure like like wealth and
people eyes on you exposes your truths
money and fame expose who you are they
don't change oh he changed he didn't
change he was [ __ ] the [ __ ] up each is
more paying attention cuz you didn't
give a [ __ ] it's also patient you know
how much I love that man especially when
I'm talking 20 when you're talking 24
loof you have such an advantage man
that's good I think people don't believe
me I guess how old are you 27
Gary really you look great patience
[Music]
patience comes with being broke I think
a lot of people were broke struggle with
patience cuz they just want to get the
[ __ ] out I think broke actually creates
short layers I think you could either
take it that way or you take it as a
person honestly man I'm always honestly
like this bro honestly honestly this is
why I'm obsessed with positivity and
mindset and parenting like we can debate
this all the way through if you're good
you're good this [ __ ] is so basic you're
good
you're just good just try to get people
to be good you know like perspective now
I think the big thing that super duper
Kyle and rust and all these guys are
gonna deal with it was the same thing
young jock and all those guys
what is the thing that you do to then
once you have that moment to have
longevity what's your answer is very
simple to me on this its undefeated
meaning there have been one hit wonders
long before young jock yes right so so
Mike Mike my thought on this is very
simple the following the interview
talked about I stood in that window as
long as I possibly read
yeah he's the longest yeah everybody
else is we talked about
yeah my fondness is very simple
perfection scares the [ __ ] out of me I'm
very sexy yeah I see so many of my
homies I Tory what I'm worried about
with you
I'm perfection scares the piss and I
don't know right it's just quick read
I'm like I hope it's not that cuz if
it's that that's real hard to break
through wait I mean I think the truth
plays out like you know like for example
Trinidad James I'm super intrigued by
him right now because I think he is like
right on the pedestal of the last decade
of hip hop one-hit wonders and like I'm
watching what he's doing right now and
I'm like interacting a little bit within
I'm like [ __ ] man it'll be really
interesting to see if he's got anything
else in the can but my big thing is that
being a one-hit wonder is better than
being a no-hit wonder I really do
believe that meaning meaning it all
comes down to the psyche
there's people back to being grounded
back to you saying Gary you could do
that but the 99 can't with like the
whole like right here's my thing there's
people who've been one-hit wonders for
child stars we focus on all the people
that got [ __ ] up we don't look at the
macro math we focus on the 13% that
couldn't handle it and explode it in
front of our faces without understanding
the 87% there was plenty of stars of
punky brewster and growing pains that
live nice [ __ ] lights and like make
funny jokes maybe like we focus on the
correct correct like to me it's like
when I talk about that when I talked
about the sneaker project I really meant
it I don't know if people like I'm
always confuse
like people what people are thinking
like I would have thought it was
phenomenal if we were sitting here in 15
years be like Nora you thought you could
have us like there's nothing more fun
than having your buddies make fun of you
a bawd a [ __ ] that you failed on like
somebody like you you said something
about planetary apps I was so like I was
dying because what I was like I was like
okay [ __ ] I'm literally gonna
have a Netflix especially that's gonna
be downloaded more than you you [ __ ]
comedian like you either have that like
you either but this is a truck giving
you my truth you either have that gear
we're like we're right there's a pre log
to the prologue thank you there's a
prologue where d-roc says it's not gonna
work but the good stop verdict out is
the verdicts out I want [ __ ]
dominated the energy that you're
deploying right now versus the reality
of your energy which was like audacious
like post-production like this isn't
gonna work nobody wants to hear your
arms and ooze and I'm gonna clean it up
and I'm like you're not gonna clean
anything I of course you do I think you
could still have you to Hollywood
[ __ ] do you know what I think your
career would be at if you threw more non
polish stuff at scale you'd be in outer
space
okay okay I'm just consider you're gonna
kill that no you're not considering it
you're gonna you're gonna do it and
you're gonna do a straw [ __ ] destroy
it so
it's less about that it's just about the
thought so you better start [ __ ]
recording his demos when you think about
[ __ ] about the process of making songs
and put that [ __ ] out just tweet it
listening to you like walking down the
street right now be like Cleopatra but
none of them take the drums that [ __ ]
I was listening the [ __ ] Coldplay
last night and that new [ __ ] joy and
Mike Boyd centers and rap cabbies oh
[ __ ] they're like just eight minutes and
13 seconds and what's going through your
dome out my time the song comes out you
know you're gonna get them on it before
it came out my turn my turn ready for
the culture for your culture just put
some [ __ ] out here's my biggest problem
stuff has to come out like like so many
baby yes like I know I'm right you know
why let's do something to culture right
now you guys ready like let's look at go
like like to breath and guys and a white
guy like they're strong he's ready to go
to Caroline's like right like right
tonight I was you know like what like I
had the sweet chicken and we can't like
here's what I know there's so much good
that never sees the day of life the and
you know you know what the little
astrick I want to put on Gary's thing is
that like to the briny [ __ ] and put all
your Studios oh by the way that's you
know what I could high-low yeah ha don't
do [ __ ] in the middle do your Netflix
special but you should be putting out
[ __ ] a one-minute video straight to
your [ __ ] face social commentating on
Instagram called on the way to work
every day
I want to hear that would be the only
thing I would consume you're hot take on
the door I love you Bama that's it three
second video
there's just highs we are so lucky we
have production companies we have
production companies and distribution in
our hand for free this food do you know
what [ __ ] prints would do if this
[ __ ] existed
like are you kidding that man that man
[ __ ] you know mad I was when they
found all those songs in Princes [ __ ]
ball like genuinely mad those things
should have seen the light of day
imagine I mean you know how much more
fun it would be if we had 57 more Big E
songs just the biggest thing is just
like man I don't know it's never been a
better time to be an artist and like I
still think you're buying
he's either saying I'm today started as
a comedian or max outt yeah he's our
personal friends well max out so I got a
max out this year so usually I can write
a new half-hour can I do seven I think
four or with the tools of the day ready
let me just say something real quick
or if the tools of the day how many
cooks run through your head in a week
okay cool great just be honest no listen
I love you for that like this is the
point my big thing is I think we need to
let people into our process more because
if we do and we put it out it may lead
to the thing we're looking for
so for example I've been talking about
perfectly parented the book that I've
been wanting to write for the five years
a rare thing for me to be I believe in
it's so much of hyping it like this
[ __ ] guy you just told me about I
feel like I'm hyping this mystical thing
I feel by the time I write perfectly 400
like every parent on earth is gonna buy
it yet the biggest progress I've ever
made imperfectly parented six was track
six was track six of [ __ ] you know
the airplane project like it's the first
time I really like that like I started
putting some of the parents stuff on wax
some out all right
oh god so glad we did it we did it yeah
I'm really glad this happened
we know how to edit insert d-roc knows
exactly I'm taking it right now [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] make people cry they're
gonna laugh so hard what I am greatest
night ever
[Music]